we're now less than three months away
from apple's annual september event
where they basically always show off
a brand new apple watch model and this
year
we're expecting the series seven and
based on a lot of rumors that have been
going around for months now
there are some pretty high expectations
even from myself
since i've been thinking of upgrading my
wife series 4 apple watch
to the new series 7 coming in just 3
months
but unfortunately we just got a new
report from a very reliable leaker
which shows the dire reality of how
boring this year's apple watch could be
so before i get into his new report and
the other two big reasons why
i don't think you should wait for this
upcoming watch
i want to go through some of the
previous leaks and rumors that were
giving us
such high expectations but before we
jump into those leaks make sure you're
subscribed right now because we're
trying to reach a million subs by the
end of the year
and we would greatly appreciate it if
you helped us out almost two years ago
the economic daily news reported
that apple is going to be bringing a
brand new micro led display
to the apple watch as soon as 2020
and obviously that didn't happen
bloomberg actually said the same thing
over three years ago
but now that we're in the landscape of
chip supply
shortages with mini led chip production
for the ipad pro
struggling to keep up it doesn't seem
like micro led is going to be ready for
the apple watch this year
now of course micro led has been apple's
end goal for the apple watch because
it's supposed to make it thinner
and lighter than before but as you'll
see in the brand new report that we just
got
it doesn't seem like it's coming over a
year ago the verified claim that the
series 7 launching in 2021
would feature a touch id sensor that
would be used to authenticate purchases
and
everything else and that might actually
happen because we've been seeing a lot
of rumors of the iphone 13
finally getting an under display touch
id sensor so it would match up
perfectly and what's really interesting
is that a few months ago
a new patent granted to apple showed a
touch id sensor built into the side
button
which actually looks very similar to the
new touch id power button on the ipad
air 4.
so that might make a lot of sense for
apple to do and apparently
they're working on an under display
camera which would actually be
really cool but here is by far the most
exciting report that we got
in terms of the apple watch series 7.
ming chi kuo a fairly reliable leaker
said that we should expect a brand new
form factor
for this year's watch and if we take a
look at where apple has been going with
the recent
design changes it's pretty obvious that
apple's going to try to give it a more
flat design
like in this very nice looking render
and making it even better
quo mentioned that apple would be coming
out with new innovative health
management functions
with the new series seven and the most
rumored one
we're all expecting is of course blood
glucose monitoring
this has been rumored for years but we
haven't actually seen it because of how
difficult it is
to check blood sugar levels without the
traditional method of pricking your
finger
but recently et news reported that this
feature
will actually be debuting on the apple
watch series 7
potentially using an optical sensor to
do it however
a lot of people are skeptical because no
one really has this type of technology
right now
so apple would have to invent some
totally new tech to make it happen
and a couple of months ago mark german
from bloomberg
said that apple may launch a new rugged
apple watch model
for extreme sports as soon as this year
apparently apple employees are
internally calling it the explorer
edition
which would have the same functionality
as a standard apple watch
but with extra impact resistance and
protection
and then going further he mentioned that
apple is working on
new swim tracking features for the apple
watch as well but the absolute banger
leak that recently
came out a few weeks ago was from john
prosser
who apparently got his hands on images
of a brand new apple watch design
with flat sides and a totally redesigned
speaker grill layout
i've gotta say that these renders by
ian's elbow look absolutely amazing
and they look perfectly in line with
what you'd expect from apple
looking similar to the new iphone and
the imac design
with those flat sides and according to
john source
apple has been working on experimental
colors for the apple watch
including a new green so what if apple
is thinking of giving the watch
the same colors as maybe the ipad air
which would be a pretty cool marketing
move from apple so as you guys can see
based on all of those very exciting
leaks and rumors
we've all got some pretty massive
expectations
for the apple watch series seven but
sorry guys
this brand new report from bloomberg's
mark german is about to burst your
bubble
first off i want to mention that mark is
one of the most reliable apple leakers
out there
with basically 90 accuracy which is even
more impressive
when you consider the fact that his
rumor count is now over 400 rumors
and while everyone including myself
thought that the m1x macbook pros were
coming at wwdc
he was saying the complete opposite and
he was right
so let's get into his new report mark
says that the new apple watch series 7
is coming with a few improvements
namely a faster processor improved
wireless connectivity
and an updated screen apple is
apparently testing a model with thinner
display borders and a new lamination
technique
that brings the display closer to the
front cover
he even said that the new watch is
likely to be slightly thicker overall
but not in a way that's noticeable to
the user now this detail is very
interesting because it makes it seem
like micro led
is finally coming but with all of the
supply chip shortages going around
i honestly don't think it's ready or
else mark would have specifically
mentioned it
and if micro led was actually coming in
this year's apple watch series 7
it would have likely made it thinner and
lighter like we heard from the previous
reports
instead of making it thicker like mark
is saying in this brand new report
and yes the new faster processor is
exciting but to be honest
the current s6 chip in the series 6 is
20 faster than the s5 chip
but in day to day use you can't really
notice any difference because both chips
are already fast enough to run watch os
just fine so i don't even think we
really need
a much faster chip and as far as
wireless connectivity improvements
apple could potentially bring 5g to the
apple watch
but if you think about it 4g is already
draining battery life
very quickly and as we all know 5g is a
huge
battery hog and in reality you don't
really need super fast 5g speeds on an
apple watch
so maybe apple's just gonna be upgrading
the bluetooth spec
to the new 5.2 version which is gonna
make it more future proof
for the next few years of iphones but
here is where mark's new report gets
very depressing apparently apple had
previously aimed to put a body
temperature sensor in this year's model
but it's likely getting delayed until
next year
and on top of that the long-awaited
blood sugar sensor is
unlikely to be ready for a commercial
launch for several more
years and making it even worse mark says
that the new rugged extreme sports
edition
won't arrive until next year at the
earliest
so all of those exciting features are
getting delayed
so i guess in reality the best hope for
the apple watch series 7
is the new redesign that jon prosser
showed off
a few weeks ago but if apple was
planning the redesign for this year's
watch
then mark german would have likely
mentioned it since he's usually the
first to mention apple product redesigns
and on top of that even john prosser
himself
thinks that the redesign he showed off
could be delayed until next year
just listen to this clip from his video
in fact everything goes by code names
behind the scenes so this source wasn't
even
able to confidently say that this was
apple watch series 7.
for all we know this could also be
series 8. so yeah
john is saying that there's a chance
that the redesign is not coming until
the series 8
which would actually make sense and
match up to mark german's new report
which is basically making the series 7
look quite
boring missing out on the features that
people actually wanted
and that's why i don't think it's worth
waiting for it and my other reason for
not waiting
is because the current apple watch
series 6 is on sale
right now on amazon being a full 70
off for both the 40 millimeter size and
the 44
millimeter size if you use the links
below so the main question that each
person has to answer for themselves
is this is it worth waiting another
three months
for the series 7 which could potentially
be a very boring update
or should you just buy the current
series 6 for a killer deal
right now and enjoy using it throughout
this entire
busy summer that's all up to you to
decide but if you enjoyed this video
go ahead and click the circle about to
subscribe for more videos like this one
definitely check out one of those two
right there thanks for watching and
we'll see you in
the next video